dig dig dig dig welcome back to the JN
and Julian podcast this is
carcast 2K
17 oh the last one we did was 2016 right
yeah hold on one sec I just remembered
that I forgot to do the pre-roll
sponsors at the beginning yeah oops well
this episode of podcast is brought to
you by wink wink is a great service
where they deliver wine to your front
door uh they select wine BAS on a taste
test that you take and then they just
deliver it to your door and it's
handpicked for you right now go to
wink.com Jen Julian for a special deal
also brought to you by mandies mandies
has the hottest coolest underwear in
town currently on my butt go to
meundies.com jul more on that in a
second sorry I didn't do that
sooner we're back in the car for a
podcast we literally haven't done this
this here yeah like you guys liked the
last one cuz it's just like a nice chill
ride of us going get some late night
food I think last time we were going to
Sprinkles Cupcakes to get cupcakes so
we're doing a similar Mission but even
though like I feel like were you you
weren't vegan in that one maybe no I
wasn't but the like sprinkles doesn't
make a gluten-free vegan cupcake they
make gluten-free cupcake or vegan but
not both they don't like both but this
time Julie where are we going we are
going to dut friend which is in Eagle
Rock so that's a bit of ways away uh but
they have a whole the whole place is
vegan every right every donut un every
donut every topping is vegan they also
have gluten-free and vegan donuts and
the I mean the place when we get there
it will be slammed every single night
they're slammed even on week nights but
they're open kind of late they stay open
late because they're smart uh but yes
like everywhere else in Los Angeles
where if you're hungry and it's after
10:00 p.m. you're [__] but it's not
even that late right now it's that late
but even still things start to close at
like 9: yeah so we figured hey we need
donuts we need a the podcast let's just
do it in the car we do need donuts we do
need donuts we always need donuts we
need donuts we um so uh we're we're
actually leaving to Vegas tomorrow uh I
know we can talk about it right now
because the podcast is going up on
Monday but we can't talk about it like
in real life right now yeah so it's
Monday for you guys uh otherwise we
wouldn't be saying this um we are going
to Vegas this weekend we have will have
gone to Vegas to surprise our good
friend Shan and Chris melberger uh it's
Shan's Birthday Chris is in on it though
Chris is in on it so Chris took her and
a bunch of friends to Vegas uh they're
out there having fun right now I think
they actually they were delayed like 5
hours cuz of weather what like weather
from New York yeah yeah cuz they're
flying in New York I was like well
weather in Vegas kind of stays the same
so uh they're probably getting there
actually tonight not they're probably
still in the air honestly um yeah so
we're going to show up tomorrow we're
flying into Vegas and we're going to
surprise them and uh have a little
weekend in Vegas I'm excited to fly to
Vegas I've never flown to it is nice man
I got to tell you oh it's
just it's a 1 hour flight you're just
going to start with that already I'm
starting with this yes uh it's a 1 hour
flight okay into the Desert Wide Open
kind of a beautiful flight honestly
because it's really cool landscape
you're looking at the flat [__]
desert wait so is it an hour like I like
to measure my flights like you know it's
like a half an hour from when you take
off to when you're like cruising speed
and then it's half an hour from when
they start telling you minutes of
cruising cuz it's 15 takeoff 15 Landing
oh okay yeah so there's it's a it's like
the flight didn't exist and it's so nice
um but yeah there's there's no traffic
jam when you're getting into Vegas
there's n none of that uh cuz i' had
never been to Vegas until I moved to Los
Angeles and drove there I've never flown
there from
anywhere yeah I only flew there when I
flew there you flew there with Josh
that's right and Arnold yep we did that
a little boys night uh that was like
years ago that's crazy was it fun oh it
was it was really fun I loved it you
guys saw that Michael Jackson show we
did we saw Michael I prefer so we've
done like two trips in a row and this
year we're going to try to do our third
um Every Spring but I like last year's
trip way better we went to Gatlinberg
that was way more fun like that that was
yeah except okay I love Gallenberg and I
had gone there with uh meory Hart for
hey USA and I had a really good time
it's a wonderful place except you guys
went there and then the you guys thought
about taking that helicopter tour and
then the day after like people died in
that helicopter okay so we we didn't we
didn't even think about it we drove by
and almost did it like so there was this
helicopter tour we drove by we said hey
that would be really really fun Should
we do it and we all kind of debated it
for a second but then we realized like
we had other things we want to do more
so we left literally the next week that
exact helicopter tour company had like
two or three people killed in a in a
crash which is nuts and then what eight
8 months later there was giant fires
that took all like all of these yeah
that was so sad oh man those cabins all
wrecked who was telling us that that
that was like arson yeah it was arson
who was telling us that I think Jay
Cyrus maybe who who was we were talking
about was Jus yeah that's so [__] like
someone just lit Gatlinburg on fire
you're a [__] up person yeah how dare
you what a lovely delightful place
you're a [__] up person to light
anything on fire so [__] off go to jail
for our unless you're spraying axe on
the floor at by the pool as a
13-year-old and then lighting it with
your lighter to be like that's dope as
[__] which is something I did you did
that maybe you were one of those kids
for a little it was a sage I had a
couple of those friends that would like
sit in their bedroom and take a bottle
of hairspray and then a lighter and do
that thing and make a little blowtorch
yeah yeah yeah too much for me I wasn't
one of those kids I never got too bad
about it I only did it a little bit and
then I feel like I still know people
that never grew out of that and they're
really annoying to be around yes yes
anytime there's light around it's just
it's their time to F dog you're an adult
stop lighting things on fire yeah um
speaking of carcast one of my favorite
comments I read about the last carcast
one of you said it it's like I was in
the back seat just going on a ride with
you guys and that's like so cool it is
pretty cool um we've improved our setup
I think uh this time we have an a better
lens that can kind of see in the dark
better um yeah well last time we had to
have the light on in order for you to
see anything which is a little
distracting like it's distracting enough
to have a camera set up in the car and
be like talking and might but then also
have the light on so yeah this is nice
like you don't have to have the light
blaring yeah although you claim that
that's not distracting for you as a
driver generally I'm okay with the light
on in the inter I can't it makes me
Furious it's I like as a kid anytime I
would turn the light on the car my mom
and dad be like yo turn it off I can't
drive like that I never had that problem
my problem is it attracts attention to
your car like if you're driving at night
and you see a car with their light on
inside their cabin it's so easy to see
what's going on in there so if we're
filming ourselves driving the last thing
we want is to draw attention to the fact
that we're just driving along Venture a
Boulevard filming our
faces which is where we are right now um
it's a lovely night how
lovely I'm just like I'm terrified of us
doing a car cast someday and like
something crazy [__] happening cuz
we're out in the world right now we are
at the whim of the universe yeah we're
not protected by we're not our podcast
safe space stained old green screen dude
okay real talk though that our beautiful
green screen it's not like the most
expensive one you can buy it's like made
of neoprene I'm sure we could get it dry
cleaned but because there's like an inch
Gap in the back door in that podcast
room it got water damage on it yeah I'm
pissed it's luckily though the part that
got water damage is not on camera it's
seeping that way though like it's
spreading so we actually are considering
getting it Dred clean and if that
doesn't work we'll have to just get
another one but yeah there's that's like
one of three doors in our houses that in
our house that literally isn't sealed at
the bottom like if it rains it will
flood yeah it just comes into the house
it just comes into the house yeah it's
like hey
fam we just live we live in a large tent
yeah we do it's just like in our last
house how like the Cockroaches would
come in oh my God that was worse though
that was way worse that was way worse
remember the flying cockroach and bed
oh oh my God like if we didn't find that
thing and get rid of it I wouldn't have
slept in there we would have to burn the
house down burn the whole house the
whole house down that was okay there
were two flying things in that in that
old bedroom that I will remember for the
rest of my life one that flying
cockroach and two marbles flying off the
bed do you remember that out of nowhere
like he just he he got in this way he
like had something come over him
standing on top of this bed and mind you
our bed is about 3 and 1/2 ft tall so
that's like a cliff to Mr Marbles he's
not he doesn't just jump off the bed he
gets a full-blown running start from the
middle of the bed to the edge and then
just dive bombs to the floor and we both
saw it and we were like why did he do
that he was like in a mood like he was
real hyper and like got himself going
and he landed and he was fine I was like
he's going he's going to break all his
legs he he stuck the landing and it was
like what's up fam I'm down here now I
can't believe that I can't believe that
we both saw it cuz that's the type of
thing that happens and one of us sees it
and the other will never believe that
you know what it's like yeah no
seriously it's like when you see a
squirrel or like a small animal Jump an
incredibly long or far High distance for
no reason and you're like did that just
[__] happen that's what it looked
like like the squirrel at the baseball
game yeah the one sail sa that's like
one of the best videos on the internet
that's a pretty great video seriously
that in Corgi feeding time yeah that
one's overrated I like I like the awall
nation squirrel Corgi feeding time I
Believe I Can Fly sloth that one's
[__] That's a classic That's a
classic sorry for going on this tangent
of the best videos on the internet oh no
it's okay this is uh this is one of the
bars that we like to go to it's called
Firefly we went there and the first time
we hung out with John Cochran was at
that par oh is that where we are yeah
this we're in Studio City now how do you
not know where we are well cuz I wasn't
paying attention I'm just sort of
looking around
um I've lived here for what like 5 years
and I still don't really know my way
around that well I would give you more
[__] if you've lived in the valley for 5
years but you've only been in the valley
for like two and a half yeah Los Angeles
is a gigantic City B
City it's not like you can get to know
the subway either like you'd have to
like know how to drive everywhere all
time yeah there's no there's no point I
mean unless unless you're um a regular
Subway user to get to like work or
something that happens on a schedule
there's no reason for you to know the
subway routes like for me uh when I went
to Chapman I took the subway from Orange
literally to Downtown LA and then to
cver City so I had to know that route
and like for instance Jason he takes the
subway to work oh that's Co from the
valley yeah because it's it's smart cuz
it works perfectly the subway the bus no
he takes the subway how there's not a
Subway here well it's a it's a railway I
mean sometimes it's under ground no no
it does go underground though la la
Union Station there's a whole subway
station at there's like five different
lines underground you the small part of
the city but it's not a it's not a
Subterranean subway system well it's
partially Subterranean so like part of
the route is Subterranean part of it is
above ground no it's there's no
questioning it I literally took it for
years I'm kidding okay um but yeah like
no like you said you kind of just need
to know how to drive everywhere which is
a lot more daunting than but I've also
lived in like a couple of cities like
you grew up here no you're right you're
right but I didn't grow up in the valley
I literally spent zero time here growing
up so let me know when you when you have
to learn your third or fourth city or
whatever driving through it gets
confusing you want me to let you know
yeah let me know okay I I'll be sure to
let you know I'll be sure to just like
tap you on the shoulder be like hey
remember when you told me to let you
know well now you know oh my God you're
a [__] I am a [__] oh babe do you watch
the office because now we're passing by
stop oh my God please there's a landmark
here please send help to4 internet
Street okay I don't give a [__]
go to a talent agency her name is Martha
every time we drive past this area well
it's still that place it do you remember
the time that for like hours we were
searching for that stupid set or
whatever yeah we went we drove up on
satco in Van eyes which is where they
filmed the office and we tried to find
the actual really stupid we didn't find
it no we didn't find nothing happened
well not nothing happened we saw a lot
of familiar territory none of it was
familiar to me it was boring that's that
sounds like yours and your fault
only that was an legal U-turn probably
right so you think like when when you
first when we first started dating and I
would drive us anytime I would make a
U-turn you were like yo that's illegal I
literally thought it was but it's not
and in California in a lot of States
specified I know that but that's
something I didn't know yeah I know
because I've driven out of state with
you and I'm like Julian you can't just
U-turn in whatever state you want boy
when we went to Oregon remember we had
to look it up I was wrong yes that was
like the one time I've ever been wrong a
lot of most places on the East Coast you
can't just make an U-turn anywhere you
feel like it you will get in big trouble
you will get a ticket you will get
pulled over trust me I've tried it
sometimes you just got to do the U-turn
no there's a Street in Boston I'm pretty
sure it's Arlington or somewhere around
not the place Arling the street
Arlington I'm afraid of where we're
going right now cuz I don't know where
it
is what you can do it okay I believe in
you pick pick away and go but there's
it's like literally forever and ever and
ever and there's no place to turn left
or right and like turn around yeah like
if you turn right then you just have to
turn right back again onto Arlington
like you can't you can't get to the
other direction you know and so I
finally was so lost and I had my notes
written out like cuz I had gotten Map
Quest directions and my printer wasn't
working so I handw wrote out my
directions for myself and I was so lost
I'm like I have to turn around or else
I'm never going to be able to find this
place so I did a u-turn and it got
pulled me over immediately wow but then
he was like I showed him my notes and I
was like this is where I'm going and
then he turned on his cop lights and
drove me there that's I followed him so
you had an escort basically yeah you
remember printing out Map Quest yes God
man how inefficient was that why did you
what do you mean why did I of course I
did how would I have brought it up if I
didn't do it I did it like my whole
entire childhood and like all through
High School how how your whole child
childhood you you printed out map quest
to what walk we as a family anytime we
were going somewhere like for instance
all my baseball games that were out
[__] God knows where we always had
Map Quest it's just crazy to think that
you had to print those [__]
directions out remember when we had an
Uber driver recently that tried to
convince us that map quest had the best
directions yes oh we're driving past
Vivid Entertainment isn't that what they
make porn what really yeah how do you
know that don't they how do you know
that okay now it's story time yeah but I
also was like a huge fan of John Jameson
back in the day is she wrapped by Vivid
Entertainment no no no no no like not
anymore she like did her own company and
stuff so wait did I want to know more
about Vivid Entertainment I don't know I
I actually I'm just talking out of my
ass I really don't know pun intended cuz
porn but we are in the valley like this
is where a lot of porn gets shot you
know that right yes I do know that
that's this is where a lot of everything
gets shot but as well but um like when
we were renting houses and stuff in LA
and you know we go through the whole
process of they're like all right what
do you do for a living and like we need
your proof of income or whatever like
yeah I make videos and they're like okay
is it porn and I'm like you know they
won't bat an eye when they ask you cuz
it's just a common thing yeah I'm like
no it's just for YouTube they're like
okay cuz if you make porn you know and
and you're renting it out to shoot porn
or whatever you you can't be like near
schools and like within this certain
radius of that oh God remember that I do
remember that and I was like no it's I
it's not porn I'm not
lying do you think that I'm lying cuz
I'm not we're not going to shoot porn
here or or every time you had your uh
DSLR set up in your bedroom and a
cleaning lady came and saw it and you're
like oh my God I'm so embarrassed cuz
this is 100% looks like I'm shooting
porn it's like a camera and like lights
pointing in a bed like that's what I
would think there's really nothing else
to think like unless you're very in tune
with who you are or what the internet is
it's there's no doubt in your mind it's
like they just they just [__] and
filmed wow good for them and they left
the camera out like they don't even care
for me to watch for me to watch it's
actually they press they press the the
playback button so that when I go to
clean I can watch it while I
clean there's Universal Studios right up
here and then this is an LA Fitness that
just is kind of a [__] fight have you
ever been there yeah I went there with
chimmy once that's the one he goes to
well no it's a bit of a [__] it's just
so C
it's like the one on Sova you know it's
like these big brand new state-ofthe-art
La fitnesses that everyone wants to go
and socialize at and so that you can't
like work out that's why I my LA Fitness
of choice is like the dungi crappiest LA
Fitness I've ever yeah cuz there's
people there no one's there it's empty
it's in a basement I don't even think
Ellie Fitness knows that it's still
open like they there were a couple times
where I didn't have my card to get in
there and they were just like yeah
you're fine like yeah I don't think that
they care if you just walk in there no
they were just like why are you giving
me your card this is a Fight Club you
can just walk
in we don't we don't really we we're not
think that's a porno [__]
entertainment DG entertainment that
looks like a porno [__] building I
don't know what that is if any building
ever looked like a porno building it's
that
ew that makes me feel weird that
building did look sus yeah sus so um do
you have any idea what Donuts you're
going to get tonight cuz I don't even
know I always forget and then I want to
look at I want the plain glazed one with
this whipped cream and just like a fresh
strawberry like the first time that I
went there I was like no that one's too
plain like I kind of want one of the
like more special ones yeah but it
really is like that good yeah it tastes
like real fresh whipped cream oh God
it's what is it coconut whipped cream
what I believe so I don't really even
know and this strawberry whatever they
do to it it's fresh but like it it's not
like any fresh strawberry I've ever had
it's like a giant it's like they just
picked it off the vine right
there yeah but it like tastes so good
it's like sugary sweet it's like a
strawberry shouldn't be that sweet yeah
it's really good they also have um a
green tea flavored uh glaze right it's
it's like the green um glaze on the
regular donut with like the sesame seeds
on top it's lit and it's so delicious
because it it's like a hint of savory
you know but like then totally sweet it
tastes like you're having green tea ice
cream but on a donut it's lit I I'll
probably have to get that one because
now I'm just like making myself I know
know I'm hungry wet about it ew ew you
did not what you don't get wet for
donuts you can't just say no you can't
say that I can't say that no what you
got to take it back okay I'll take it
back can I unsay that don't be nasty
it's kind of like me wanting Callin to
untweet that [__] he tweeted the other
day what did he tweet the he tweeted
that vile gift of that like weird
animation of that guy spinning around
and his junk just knocks this girl's
head head off almost everything they
call in tweets is V it's like you can't
unsee it and I was like you need to find
a way to activate Twitter's untweet
function and untweet this now
immediately or I'm deleting myself or
I'm deleting everything I'm just going
off the internet because you didn't
untweet
this so now we are uh going over the
hill and entering Hollywood we're going
to pass the Hollywood Bowl in a second
have you ever been to the Hollywood Bowl
no I have guess who I saw though oh I'll
give you a
hint okay it's a color and a
month
uh Blue October yes wait really yeah I
saw Blue October at the Hollywood po who
yeah my dad was like a huge fan of them
and he brought me I'm not positive but I
think he brought no no no okay so it's a
different time my dad one time meet myad
is the biggest Bruce Springsteen fan in
the entire world like I don't think I
don't think there is a bigger one no I'm
I'm honestly serious like there is not a
bigger Bruce
Spring he is he is the biggest Boss Fan
ever anyway for my birthday one year he
thought you know what I love him so much
that that I love him in oh [__] sorry
sorry sorry we're like halfway in the
intersection right now oops we're good
it's a tricky intersection it's a tricky
one we're right um babe no what we're
fine bab you're making a scene now this
is like the entrance so yeah it's like
blocked off this looks like a street I
think you're fine well there's also no
one here either we're fine or we're not
so o this is the place where I called
the cops on that driver that was like
driving backwards remember he was he was
dri he was reversing and he was driving
the wrong way but he just kept doing
laps he didn't leave I was really scared
I thought he was wasted I don't know I
was going but yeah go ahead for your
birthday for my birthday my Dad figured
he loved Bruce sping enough for both of
us so he bought me tickets to go with
him to the Bruce Spring team concert
stop that's such a dad thing to do such
a dad thing to do God that just made me
so nervous that like that intersection
what was that oh you're okay I'm okay
yeah anyway I'm honestly really
comfortable more than anything and I
think it's because my do no
oh it's like first of all why are you
pulling over and second you pull it out
of here PS so your wardrobe is on point
but what about the stuff not everyone
gets to see make sure your underwear is
on point too with me and these what is
NE it's a seriously soft Feelgood
underwear delivered to your underwear
drawer they're designed in LA and made
from softer than soft micro modal fabric
it's three times softer than cotton they
have all the coolest designs you could
ever imagine and each month they have a
new signature series of underwear
released for your butts pleasure right
now if you want to save time and money
every month then get yourself a monthly
subscription which the underwear just
shows up every month I'm telling you
that is one of the best feelings when
the fresh underwear shows up every month
no matter what it's so nice but if
you're not ready for that you can just
get a pair and right now you can uh get
20% off your first pair of mandies um
mistake I was mistaken last week it was
50% this week it's 20% off uh you get
20% off your first pair of mandies at
meundies.com
Julian check them out also we are
sponsored by wink this week when you
have a great glass of wine it enhances
the moment but what's even nicer is when
you don't have to go shop for that wine
when I used to shop for wine I would
literally pick the prettiest bottle and
I would buy it and it did not yield good
results wink gives you a pallet profile
quiz where they recommend interesting
wines customized to your specific taste
uh no more going to the store and doing
what I did you can have wink do all the
hard work for you they will send you
wine and they'll introduce you to new
and rare different wines that you never
would have had before right now you can
join and Skip uh skip any month and
cancel any time plus wink will have 100%
satisfaction guarantee so you never pay
for a bottle that you don't like it's
delicious right now you get $20 off your
first order when you go to try wink
that's TR R ywi nc.com Jenna Julian and
they will even handle the shipping for
you thank you
sponsors so are the best they are the
best supporting the J Julian podcast so
right now we have to get on the freeway
and we got to go get donuts so we are
going to take a little break and we'll
be right back and for you it's going to
be a millisecond the we've tried it
before the audio is too loud on the
highway plus it's a little distracting
and we have to so we're going to go get
our donuts and we'll be back with our
Donuts right now and we're back oh my
God first of all I think a nice shout
out is due to Donut friend they just
comped our donuts and they were so sweet
to us no reason reason people are so
[__] nice man if you guys want
fantastic Donuts to do that like I'm
more than happy to throw all of my money
at you donut friend they're so nice like
H and anyway so what did you get babe
and a girl named Kyla like right after
we left was like you're wonderful and I
was like I'm going to cry I have donuts
and you're saying such nice things it
was a lot of really wonderful things
that just happened and then on top of it
all we have Donuts is this are we making
like a carcast SL mukbang right now yeah
I think we're doing a Muk thing is this
a [__] M ASMR Muk thing we don't get
allor if you guys don't like eating
sounds
you can get out I got I got this this is
one of my favorite ones it seems like it
should be simple it's just got like
whipped cream and strawberries in the
middle and I've never had this one but I
wanted something chocolate so I got this
mint chocolate one it's got crushed
Oreos on top I literally got a cream
cheese donut cuz I wanted something a
little Savory and then I got a chocolate
glazed donut you got a cream cheese yeah
that's what this is all right are we
doing it
cheers
[Music]
o oh my God
yep that is so good is that the cream
cheese one yeah is it good it's so good
do it taste like a sweet Bagel mhm a
swaggle swaggle baby swiggle me so what
do you think of our new series Doos so
this happened in Amur comedians getting
tacos yeah have you watched last week's
the my final vlog of last week we ate
docos in the car which is hot dogs in
corn tortillas and we call them
doos and I what happened was like we I
left the camera rolling while we kind of
just ate and talked and I was like oh
I'm going to cut it up it'll be real
quick but then I sat down to edit it and
it was so funny so I literally just let
let it roll like that's why we did
carcast though that's kind of what
inspired carcast tonight us eating in
the car and having it be funny like that
so I love the new series and I would
love to implement it regularly somewhere
we're doing it right now I know it's
pretty
great but we should really eat outside
of an open mic Day by the
airport audio will be a
mess why cuz we're by the airport and
there's an open
mic could you ever do like open mic
stand up never give us your opening joke
your
killer so anyway I was walking down the
street and this dog is just looking at
me and I said hey
dog why are you looking at me and he
said
bark yay I'll be here till never goodbye
everybody I um I don't think my
humor I mean I know I if I really wanted
to I could be I could do stand up I just
I feel like it's super not something I'm
into well like anybody could there's
like a formula you could follow yeah I I
just feel like the only reason anyone
ever does standup is because that Medium
works for them or they think it could
work for them for me I it's it's hard
for me to picture that working for me
you know I like humor in the Vlogs I
like humor on the podcast just in my
normal life but to have things prepared
just seems very hard for me and I'm not
like singling myself out a special like
I know it's hard for everyone who does
stand up it's not an easy thing my dad
did it for 20 something years M
um yeah wow he got two sh this
podcast my dad doesn't get enough shout
outs shout out to my dad Mr Mory shouts
out this is so [__] good this is so
good I feel like my set would just be a
nervous selection of dad jokes
mhm you know yeah man that immediate
reaction is terrifying and then me just
laughing and then saying goodbye
everybody kind of like your radio show
except for with audience no exactly like
my radio show I know like you sit there
and record that thing but I'm there and
I'm hearing all of it yeah but I just
like Take 5 minutes to laugh at myself
and then keep going no that's pretty
great I like when you laugh at yourself
it's
cute get your box away from me oh sorry
bab I love how when you're done with
your belongings you just throw them on
me every night when we go to bed Julian
takes a pillow that he's done using cuz
he's laying down now and he throws it on
top of me no I don't I'm put it on like
your knee it's so annoying or like when
you get hot like instead of just like
neatly pushing the covers aside you just
flop them over on top of me sorry
retweet if um you
inspired I can't be the only person that
is just like constantly a thing holder
for someone else MH and like literally
your mule when we go out in the world
you ask to put things in my back bag all
the time babe your bag is so great I'm
so proud of your bag and how far it's
come it's carried all of my belongings I
hate you I love you without you I would
be losing everything everywhere I went I
would lose the stuff I feel like like a
[__] camel like a yak like you're
just putting things on me all the time
okay yep that's
fair well you just put your trash on me
I put it on armrest and it slid over to
you cuz it wanted to say
hi what fight
me God I want to go back and get more
but the line was so long
mhm and so we're in Eagle Rock which is
a really cool place a lot of young
people it's really like up and coming
pretty cool mhm there's two horses just
standing outside there outside of a bar
tied up to a pole no one's on them
they're just two horses there like
someone ride those horses to a bar like
they're in an old Western on a main road
I have a question is that legal I don't
know I wonder if that's legal I wonder
if they're like someone's horses or if
they're like police horses well You'
think they'd be they didn't have you
think they'd be cop horses cop horse
gear on no they didn't I said we're cops
okay I have question have no n Gear
on we're use our horse to snip out you
NS he's really lowkey about
it um do horses get like police
certified the way that dogs do 100%
there's no way they just grab a random
horsey and say time to chase criminals
on you yeah but you know like how a
police officer their partner is their
dog yeah it's obviously different
training cuz there's such different
animals but but if so you're if you're a
horse cop is that horse your partner the
way that a dog cop cop horse you said
horse cop it's okay what's wrong with a
horse cop it's cop horse I agree to
disagree I agree like that so that was
dramatic I want to try my second one
you're on your second one this is yeah I
would be on my third you already April
the years yeah we didn't eat dinner this
is like our dinner I know it is this is
dinner number one let's just let's not
limit ourselves please dinner number
one yeah no I I definitely think that
they 100% is training that goes into
having a horse be a law enforcement
horse but it's probably so much
different than that's not the question
though of course there's training but
are the are the horses a cop the way
that the dog is a cop no the horses are
a car they serve as the transport so
they're not cops they're not cops
they're cop cars they're cop transport
you don't see cops riding their
dogs they would if they had like 100 PB
Chihuahua though or if the cops were
small and they fit on their dogs gety up
I we when we watch this police chases
and seeing those dogs the police dogs
take down those criminals who were
shooting at police like that was amazing
police dogs are amazing mhm but just on
the way here on whatever Highway that
was we saw a car flipped over on its top
on the direction phing is in a car a cop
car speed down this street where the
horses are at like 70 M hour this street
so we're in Eagle Rock like downtown
Eagle Rock This is York Street or
Boulevard or a I don't know it's right
by donut friend and if you've been in
this area or even if you haven't this
road the main road is Tiny like there's
barely enough room for two cars to be
driving opposite directions and parked
cars it's very tiny and this police guy
in his SUV Cruiser just literally did
like 60 to 70 M hour down this street it
was crazy you're going to kill somebody
you're going to kill a cop it was so
like I couldn't believe how loud and
Fast it all was it happened so
fast but um I still need to know is a
cop a horse uh uh no it's a it's a cop
car it's a cop car there's no way a cop
so you're saying there's three types of
cop transportations yes bike car
helicopter
what there so such thing is a helicopter
cop how the [__] are you serious
helicopter you like an LAPD
copter did you say helicopter yeah get
out you're riding in the trunk on the
way home all right there's a seat back
there for you go
boy sorry
helicopter wow see that would be your
standup but like why yeah exactly but
why why does a dog get to be a cop but
not a
horse but like why why why stop at dogs
cuz a horse can't do [__] yes they can I
feel like horses are smarter than dogs
I'd like you to please give me a
scenario if you're a cop right give me a
scenario where you would you would
Retreat your own self and you would send
your horse in to do the bidding in a
situation that got hairy like you would
a dog I feel like horses are just so
underserved because you can teach a
horse how to take a person down we just
haven't utilized them for that how how
how because they would kill
them yeah they they'd kick him in the
chest and the person would be dead
instantly and also how do you
logistically how does that happen you
walk behind a horse and piss it off
that's when it kicks you in the chest
you can't have it like run backwards and
just be kicking criminals like that
doesn't work I feel like if we put
enough energy and Manpower into it we
could train horses to be
cops I don't I I would like I would I
have no words I feel like we could use
them for a lot of cop things like giving
out parking
tickets or taking down
criminals he spits out a parking ticket
yeah like you just teach him where like
what the lights on the park parking
meter means or like you put little
special horse signs on there for when
they're expired and then
they you teach them how to just give it
a stamp or something that counts as your
ticket no 100 times no you're reaching
and it's over okay but okay you have to
agree with me you just okay what you
reached so far you fell off the leg that
if you were a criminal a violent
criminal and there was a canine unit
you'd be like I feel like I could maybe
get away from that dog but if someone
had a horse
unit I would be way less scared I would
be like are you kidding now I can catch
a breath and walk for a little bit I'll
jump on it and ride it away even if a
horse gets to full speed I'll I'll
literally like you can a horse is like
you can outmaneuver yeah you out
maneuver that thing you just go to the
right climb up some stairs then what is
the horse going to do run up the stairs
make a spooky sound behind
him
no like every angle of this isn't
working like a horse is not better than
a dog as a cop as if you're if if a if a
cop's job was to run around a track
really fast horses would be great at it
but horses are really smart and they're
like people they have little
personalities they're
wonderful I mean maybe like when when
there's like a noise complaint instead
of actual cops they just send the horses
to knock on the door and just like scare
the [__] out of everyone because they're
hor it made me think of that that clip
from Ridiculousness of that guy in his
house doing that like Mexican dance on
the horse like in the living room yeah
there just like casually a horse inside
the living room with a guy donkey it was
like a donkey no it was a full grown
horse really yes and there's like a man
on it and they're doing a dance in like
their living room it's the majority of
the living room wow wow how did they get
him in the door how how did they get him
in the door frame they must have a
garage that they just opened up but how
you get him from the garage to the door
frame through the house I don't
know doesn't matter that's why it makes
it funny or it was a set maybe and it
was a movie no it wasn't a movie it
looked like it was probably on Warner
Brothers lot
31 do other countries like say you're in
Thailand sure we say you're in Thailand
do they use like elephants as cops or
India like places where there are
elephants or like decision they all
right like other places where there are
other like animals I would probably
guess they do yeah I would guess they
would utilize the the animals that are
um so if you're in Costa Rica do they
have monkey cops okay see this is
something practical cuz those
[__] are capable they can steal
everything they well that doesn't serve
a cop okay why not why when would a cop
need to
steal I don't know no uh monkeys yes
they steal just snatch someone's wig oh
my God no like monkeys would be great
for like for like uh detaining a suspect
they would like jump on them and [__]
pull their hair and punch them until
they just down wouldn't you be scared
for the safety of the
monkey um as I'd be as scared for the
safety of the monkey as I would for the
safety of a police dog because the
police dogs that are in situations where
they have to go after suspects those are
[__] hairy situations like they go
after these these people who are armed
and like you never know what crazy
[__] is going to oh that place
has vegan hamburgers
actually what are we doing I don't know
i' I've never seen it in person I've
only seen it it's called Burger Lords
I've only seen it on Twitter do you want
to pull over and get one well now we're
going to have to find parking again H
maybe we'll pull over I'll just do loops
are you serious yeah why not okay when
an Eagle Rock as they say I like to say
when in Rome around Rome cuz she hates
hearing that oh beautiful spot babe so
we'll be right back then um we can or
really yeah all right are we doing
another break yeah oh my god well we're
not going to just leave it rolling on
our empty car while we go get hamburgers
oh yeah of course so now we've had
proper dessert look they're right there
there's two horses right there horses
are right there and those are not cop
horses how difficult there a guy with a
cowboy just a guy and his wife they both
have cowboy boots on oh my God they're
taking them yep
are they their horses though they they
have to be they tied them to a tree okay
can you [__] move this at all I'm not
lying no he that going to be it's going
to mess everything up yeah but I mean
it's if you can picture what a horse
looks like that's it's right there yeah
but it looks
insane it it it looks like we're in a
movie it looks like they're just horses
in oh did you see that yeah he like
almost like bucked his face into that
guy's face on purpose like he looked
pissed all right I guess I guess we're
going to go get some burgers
so are you getting Burgers sure all
right we'll be right
back there's two [__] horses right
there I swear in my life these people
rode these horses to this bar and tied
them to a tree like a [__]
bicycle give me your phone I'll film it
with your phone
here I'm not kidding oh he's getting
honest there he goes all right I'm going
to film this we'll be right back
look it he just got on his
horse they're right there what are they
doing they're probably like ma'am you
need to leave you're you you can't bring
your horse here A horse walks into a
bar
Julian and we're back so that place was
closed unfortunately no burgers tonight
but I was right they did have a vegan I
didn't need a burger we just had donuts
for
dinner I I needed a burger I'm not okay
but no they uh they look delicious on
the menu so we might have to come back
there yeah it's pretty cool it's just
like a street window like you can just
order a burger like a like a regular
person like a regular person I love when
vegan and Gloom free places make the
experience like as normal as everyone
else has it yeah it's really nice it's
pretty nice so we're exiting Eagle Rock
right now and I still want no I have
more questions we didn't finish this all
right is a cop a horse no horse's a cop
no Transportation Transportation vehicle
for a police officer not not a police
officer because dogs are not used for
transpo they are they are officers they
have serve a purpose other than
okay I have a question
okay so if a dog like they attack and
disarm criminals or whatever yeah why
doesn't the Coast Guard use
sharks okay how would they train a shark
I don't know neither do I so how can I
answer that question maybe they could
what about dolphins why don't they use
Dolphins they just pull like a gray
white sit sit just bites his arm
off our very controversial great white
officer like oh my God project has ended
in the death of Larry oh my godar Larry
dude Larry lowkey had a coming why not
Dolphins um dolphins are smarter than
people um Dolphins I feel like you could
train but at at what moment at what
moment
though would a cop need a dolphin like a
coast guard cop but give me a scenario
they need them to go work together to
flip over that person's boat wow that is
such a specific need that's that really
trashy uh bowling lane karaoke bar that
we went whatever yeah the place is fun
that was fun it takes forever to get a
drink and they serve in plastic cups or
not at all and watered down alcohol
right water down y we don't know that
for sure and the karaoke is just the
sound system is just like oh yeah but
when Christine goes in there it's not
yeah is
yeah I watched her in person sing the
national anthem at karaoke yes we
actually we both there and it's
something that you really can't believe
unless you're seeing it with your own
eyesred it's just the best thing I've
ever seen at any karaoke night in my
entire life she actually asked to be
back in the podcast we need to have them
back on the podcast because uh you guys
[__] loved that episode cuz they're
they're the best you should have yeah I
mean there's no reason not
to
did you see Elijah tweet that screenshot
of like his videos getting demonetized
and it was like we make a dildo bong sh
like
that God man they are they are so funny
so did you see how much weed they had
for their 420,000 subscriber yeah like
that's a [__] like that was really
expensive I don't know anything about
anything but it looked like $100,000 a
weed yeah I don't [__] know it looked
like so like a lot like a lot
of a lot a lot just a lot just a lot the
whole thing is just a lot
yeah it had to have been a lot of money
yeah it looked like a lot of thousands
of dollars probably I you think so yeah
I mean I don't like I said I don't know
anything about that whole world but it
like it it was like three you know when
you get popcorn at the fair those are
the size bags they had and they had like
three or four of them and you see weed
you know bags of weed like in little
tiny bags and those cost 100 bucks right
so it's like I [__]
know I'm not a cop okay relax I don't I
don't know anything I know you're not a
horse how do you know step one of how
how to know if I'm a cop a is he a
horse no okay B I don't know you got is
on top of a horse okay no see did he
Park his horse outside of the bar I
can't so as I think you're going to clip
in that video yeah I already not [__]
lying but as we were going to check on
the hamburger place to see that it was
closed they just got on their horses and
rode away they did on the sidewalk like
boisterously yeah like this woman almost
hit someone with her horse that's why a
horse couldn't be a cop but they're on
the sidewalk like there's like street
lights that dip like almost where head
level is that on top of it didn't look
it didn't look like they had planned it
out it looked like they were just riding
a horse on a sidewalk
see how long they could stay in the bar
before they get in trouble I mean I'm
pretty proud of my timing for that joke
because when could you ever say A horse
walks into a bar when a horse yeah you
really cracked yourself up that like
that is I think that's probably top five
moments in my entire life but he didn't
walk into a bar neither of them walked
into the bar the joke but it was just
come on no come on come on give it to me
babe really wasn't come on babe give it
to me no all right no well we don't
really have any choices other to get on
the highway at this point uh so we're
going to probably close it yeah yeah
sure are you ready yeah you're going to
pull over or you just going to just go
we're just going to go off into the
night thank you guys for hanging out
though for this podcast and I hope you
enjoyed carcast 2.0 it was really fun it
was and our Donuts were really good
hopefully the quality was okay I still
like you know it's hard to know when
we're driving but we'll find out I guess
we'll find out trial and error um shouts
out to the sponsors make sure you go
check them out wink and me we appreciate
you and uh we'll see you guys next week
for another episode bye guys cops are
horses they're so not they're so not yes
they are
[Music]
bye